hey there before we go into the intro
which is fun I mean it's all right uh I
know what you're thinking slow news day
correct that means that uh we're gonna
lean into having some fun here today and
we're all very very angry I'll give you
a hand Hillary Clinton uh Rachel Ziegler
so I do want you to know that
though that happens none of the intros
that you see Alex Jones's show this
Friday bringing on people like Brian
Cowan Hodgkins new stand-up specials the
investigative journalism none of it
happens you notice no ads unless NBC
Universal or box or whoever it is claims
this episode on YouTube as their own uh
we forfeit that and we are funded
entirely by viewers like you so consider
signing up at ladder with
crowder.com89 annually you get this
wonderful hand etched girthy
hand-painted mug and all of that content
or no content the choice is yours let's
enter the muck Club Zone
there is a Fifth Dimension beyond that
which is known to man and z
a dimension beyond the reach of big Tech
and cancellation conspiracy theorists
and recalling the events of 12. we'll do
something a little bit differently we're
engaging daily content meets affordable
pricing it is The Intercept between
Illuminating conversation and jokes
the difference between truth and
mainstream media
this is the Uncharted dimension of the
Internet it's an area which we call the
mug Club Zone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we're all in good spirits today we're
all in a good mood right your leaders
are looking out for you not Ukraine and
we don't have Elites in power like
Hillary Clinton now you know what I'll
put Rachel Ziegler on there too with
snow white everything is ruined Peter
Dinklage I used to think was funny he
stood on the shoulders of the Vern
troyers of the world of the will
Ferrells and that wants to put us that
wants to pull that tiny ladder up behind
him so we'll be talking about all of
that today it's a cultural issue
I used to like him funny guy I was like
you shouldn't hire midgets because
they're midgets ah you know who else
didn't get romantic comedy leads
Dinklage Michael Clark Duncan okay
it's valid
unless was a romance show with like
Lenny with the rabbit I don't know but
my point is just
just not everything has to be a thing so
we'll you know we'll make it a thing and
hopefully we'll have some fun with it
but I do have a question uh for you if
Trump is convicted does that make you
more or less likely to vote for him
there's a lot of speculation out there
and the beauty is with the millions of
you tuning in uh you're a great sample
size does it make you feel compelled to
support him yes at this point I don't
know that anyone else could even stand a
snowball's chance in hell yeah in the
primary yes if he gets convicted I'm
absolutely 100 supporting him even more
than I'm already supporting him yes I
know and we really didn't like him in
the primaries in 2016 neither one of us
I thought he was joking around I thought
this was all a goof yeah and he ended up
winning it I think he maybe thought like
well hell I won that was a goof if he
gets a mug shot we need to make t-shirts
yeah
he'll probably already have it
copyrighted that's true that's true
that's my IP he's such a great fish good
face the best face he'll sell them yeah
all right you hear him he's off to a bad
start number two CEO Gerald that was
that bad Morgan how are you sir I'm
fantastic how are you I'm good do you
see the new like the rumble the the
thing because we have the new outro when
we go over yeah the new outro Rumble by
the way of course everyone you know uh
if you're watching on YouTube if you see
this at any point this dump button
ah just head on over to rumble yeah
we're not going to censor ourselves and
that's why we're still on YouTube but
you know every now and then they suspend
us anyway whatever hey can we get can we
get a suspension for anyone who wants
one I don't want one okay
in uh third trip it's his last day here
uh today this week anyway we love
hanging him in send in your chats let
him know you love him he's going to be
the Funny Bone Richmond Virginia this
Friday Saturday August 18th and 19th
Richmond Virginia Josh firestein what's
up good morning how you doing sir good
good I think we need the mic a little
closer to your face are you worried
about it are you worried about your
beard scratching us yeah yeah yeah I get
to get nervous it's on a mic stand you
can move it you don't have to you threw
up all morning because of some hairspray
I did it wasn't hairspray it was hair
powder it's a different it's a different
thing it's manly what yeah yeah what
it's a hair powder you put it in your
hand you decide
it's not Anthrax no it's not did you get
your hair powder from an unmarked
envelope you know Josh you could just
shower that's you're talking about dry
shampoo it's just foot powder I replaced
the word foot without hair but everyone
careful thank you for your service thank
you
he was
all right okay
before we move on here uh and there's
there's a lot to get to uh here's an
Australian uh woman
and she apparently look
no one cares let's be clear I was raised
in Canada where they would always
about the United States right because
they have the biggest small man's
complex that I've ever seen in my life
and uh they thought that we care like
they think we're sitting here going gee
I hope the Canadians like us this Aussie
chick thinks that we're going oh my gosh
I hope the broad who was raised in a
rapist and murdering penal colony likes
her flag but everyone feels and of
course you're entitled to your own
opinion the problem is when you're
entitled to an opinion and then big Tech
censors you if you make fun of said
opinion because it's stupid and I don't
mean like yo that's stupid like cool I
mean it's dumb it's unintelligent so
here is this Aussie broad who apparently
has a problem with American flags and
patriotism
cars
cars Flags Americans making your bloody
fortune and Chinese I'm like you're the
only country that I know that does this
like because we're better the only time
I think I've ever seen an Australian
flag is like on the Harbor Bridge
yeah because people are jumping off of
it like I know it's like blue and it's
got some stars on it
but I I think I could draw the American
flag so you're an idiot memory you can
make a body sculpture out of it let's
get someone else's country once I've
seen it it's enough let's pull back on
it okay
let's stay humble you come from the land
of murderers rapists and every venomous
animal known to man no one cares about
your opinion you're just not that
important and if you really hate
patriotism I demand that you Feast your
eyes on this
[Music]
America
by the way that's a real tattoo just see
100 baby did you lose a bet no no I love
this country no I know he does but
that's a painful place you should go
elope with that Aussie brother I love
our country too if you don't if you
don't like his America tattoo you might
as well get the hell out okay
font across his belly that's a sensitive
area yeah yeah I had ABS back then
though it looked really cool it was
really small yeah
and now it's just like whoa look at the
fun that guy with the dumb thing on his
belly it was uh El Nino it was Comic
Sans originally now it's a different
phone you should see my lower back
I have now
allegedly allegedly
what's that music
it's a lot of fun people have seen my
balls and his ass now
this is just one of those okay first off
quiz what is the most venomous snake in
the world not the most dangerous the
most venomous snake in the world do you
know why America is better than most
countries it can sort of be boiled down
to snakes
do you know how many people die from
snake bites in the United States each
year approximately I'm going by Road
here but I know I'm within Striking
Distance it's like five to ten you know
how many across the globe it's well into
the hundreds of thousands it's a minimum
of 80 000 in Asia every year often well
over a hundred thousand in Asia the big
four they call them these snakes now
here's the issue it's because they live
in countries where they don't have
advanced uh Medical Technology like we
do ant even they don't take care of
their own citizens and a lot of them
still have to work in these primarily
agrarian Societies or as we would know
them third world countries so they don't
survive what we survive here and they
have more venomous snakes to be clear in
Asia yeah most venomous comment below
don't cheat don't cheat
they're cheating it's the England type
end Taipan sorry from Australia yeah
there's also the coastal Taipan also a
dick but not as venomous so this is why
all snakes should be killed and
Australia needs to be nuked now actually
keep them on snake Islands yes yes send
the snakes to Australia well they have
snakes they already are there like they
did the people yeah yeah send them it's
a penal colony by the way it's a live
show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern you can watch it on Rumble a
podcast wherever it is you can consider
joining mug Club okay
Hillary Clinton
oh yeah the
foreshadowing
just yesterday she joined Rachel ma oh I
mean I mean come on how many butch-cuted
Chain Gang lesbians can you fit in a
room
Hillary Clinton joined Rachel Maddow and
uh I don't think you can I don't think
you can sort of crystallize a more
elitist out of touch clip but uh here's
what happened fancy meeting you oh I
can't believe this yeah this is not the
circumstances in which I expected to be
talking to you nor me Rachel it's always
good to talk to you but honestly
um I didn't think that it would be under
these circumstances yet another set of
indictments
shut your
it's just everything everything is just
a Redux right yeah yeah sure Crow do
something original
was that shell Crow it was Meredith
Brooks oh oh by the way still not
President right yeah okay just checking
if you're here Nick the follows a bit
about uh crozick uh Sheryl Crow remember
her titless one hit wonder from the 90s
oh he talks about her demanding we use
one square he no one hates elitism more
than Nick depal you can watch him on mug
Club at 5 p.m tonight okay this brings
us to more elitism here look I'm glad
that the United States is in a position
where we can help uh anyone in the world
you know that's why the flag is so
popular
but it doesn't mean that we have to we
should definitely and comment below hit
like too if you hey we should take care
of our own people first that's only a
novel concept to people really since the
1960s to today the idea that if you are
a superpower you need to be taking care
of the rest of the world as opposed to
at gunpoint raping them of their
resources that's kind of how Empires
existed beforehand I I don't know if you
know this evil Empires are generally
profitable not costly so um
this is my problem with what Biden is
doing of course he had no comment now
he's trying to lean too far the other
way with the Maui fires horrible tragedy
obviously the the death toll is now over
100 my hearts go out to those families
affected okay to make up for it uh
former Vice President Joe Biden is now
sending a 700 one-time payment to each
household affected ah oh 700 whole
dollars 700 whole dollars does Obama get
some
and he said don't spoil your dinner
there's plenty more where that came from
the taxpayers now 700 that sounds nice
and hey we're taking care of some of our
own citizens it makes sense
uh I just hate it when you get a check
that says like from President Joe but no
no it's not it's not your check now
here's the math that you need so
ukrainians apparently need the money
more because he's committed former vice
president by number 113 billion wow
Ukraine and Counting that's over 2 500
per person in Ukraine or an RPG 7 for
every single Ukrainian man woman and
child
oh
come in handy so just so seven hundred
dollars to people of Maui 2500 people of
Ukraine the biggest beneficiary in all
this by the way is formerly Maui but now
Ukrainian gym which I don't want to
question intense I don't think he's all
in for the cause I think he's a grifter
I think he is gaming the system formerly
Maui now Ukrainian gym by the way
real 700 bucks
how many
what is it a thousand 2200 structures is
what they said burn let's say that
there's 2 000 families or homes that
were affected by this time seven hundred
dollars really yeah really what are you
doing is that the tip are Joe yeah like
come on we're a national superpower like
we can absolutely 100 International
students we can absolutely send more
money that way like why would you
announce that and go I did it he wants
to buy votes and he knows that most of
it will be spent on meth no it's not
going to buy it
you know what the White House needs it
yeah yeah you know he's sending you a
check that's less than the covid checks
everyone got yes and in covid your house
didn't burn down and half your family
die yeah thanks Joe yeah well it's about
the price of a surfboard
oh there's like surfboards yeah yeah
they like the long boards that costs
more you can't even fly off the island
for that Joe the president's sending me
to pipeline freaking out how come uh how
come nobody sends California residents
or Oregon residents or Washington
residents money when their house is
burned down or yeah mudslides in it's
all about this timing yeah and I don't
by the way I don't think we should be
sending anyone just a blank check I
think that we should have more if we did
a whole segment on it yesterday if you
didn't watch it on mug Club because it
was a little bit more complicated had to
do the ins and outs but
maybe you could have an efficient form
of government and fulfill your one role
one thing that falls under the
legitimate purview of government is
keeping the citizens safe not reducing
the price of internet not making sure
that people have don't have to pay rent
not paying a portion of the degree for
underwater basket weaving or Afrocentric
lesbian studies at Dartmouth but keeping
people safe meaning from people who want
to kill us external forces or interior
forces internal threats that would
include a natural disaster about which
many people knew and warned but here you
go seven hundred dollars twenty five
hundred dollars for Ukraine the good
news is this is not just a Democrat
issue by the way Democrats and
Republicans have found Common Ground
Biden is uh you know in good good
company people like Mike Pence your
concern is that the ukrainians a country
most people can't find on a map who've
received tens of billions of U.S tax
dollars don't have enough tanks I think
it's a fair question to ask like where's
the concern for the United States in
that well it's not my concerned
[Music]
cash
and here you thought the show was sexist
I've never seen somebody commit
political suicide it's so wonderfully
bye Mike yeah geez does anyone like Mike
Pence no comment below no I've heard of
are you Mike Pence's fan who's that guy
yeah who's the guy with the Mike Pence
bumper sticker no he's got a pin's
tattoo
was this a Nerf commercial his own
family doesn't like him yeah I know uh
yeah it's awkward flies do oh that's
right yes they're drawn to him like
flies to Mike Pence now
well you know what this is a good
example we're a little more relaxed you
served your country what do you think
about uh sending money over to Ukraine
our hearts go out to the people of
Ukraine but you're someone who served
your country who actually thought
sometimes people say well yeah until you
fought you can't have an opinion what do
you think about sending billions of
dollars to Ukraine I think it's been too
long I think it's been too much and too
long I think uh you know at first you're
like okay we gotta help them out they're
being invaded blah blah blah but after a
certain time it's like we gotta we gotta
do something also why is nobody else
helping why is not NATO helping us out
or you know they're not paying in their
portion a few of them did it first but
then they you know why they're like hey
this is all we can give you yeah we have
to worry about ourselves the only person
to get other countries to start paying
more into NATO was President Donald
Trump well look and thank you again for
your service Josh we have to say that
yes of course single time as part of his
writer you're welcome you're welcome
Gerald if you think it's been too long
and too much
we're gonna be in trouble for that if
you think it's been too long and too
much you're really gonna love this so
apparently the uh there's a transgender
journalist from the United States that's
now the official spokesperson for the
Ukrainian military do we have an overlay
yes for that oh do we have a clip you'll
know that oh boy blood grips from it
he's eval okay Daria carrying out
genocide against both I don't believe it
it's got to be a deep face
that's not real is it is it real
I think it's really did Mission Control
confirm that it's real they sent it to
all right look we'll play it later in
the show you guys can chat below I don't
want to be faked out if it is real I
want to see it even though I just threw
up in my mouth a little bit a little bit
yeah it's Pat by the way boycotts work
and buy cops work we'll be talking about
Target reducing their sales projections
what you guys have done with Bud Light
and uh hey you know what send a send a
few of that a few of those billions uh
over this way and sign up at mug Club
because there's a lot we can do we just
look we just love poking our finger in
the chest of people who hate you it's
kind of it's
gingersnap saying it is it's a report
from Newsweek real
wow
by the way gingersnap and ladies
gingersnap you know ladies love him he's
single uh yeah he's a preference though
straight he likes a very specific type
of so does Gary they each have a type uh
and there's nothing wrong with that men
are allowed to have types are huge
unless you grew up next to a radiation
plant then you know yeah I guess you can
find ways to make it work it's my point
is that why you have the two on your arm
on the tattoo yeah yeah okay so explain
this to me again Gerald this video so
this is
real no but what is it's a trans I'm
getting there it's a transgender
gender journalist from the United States
that we apparently have exported over
there now is the official spokesperson
for the Ukrainian military because I
guess it's scary well hold on a second
pause you know who else we exported to
them who well actually not Ukraine we
exported back to Russia was The Merchant
of death oh yeah they still oh they
still really not good with trades but
don't worry we still have Brittany
Griner so that's the big deal and she
can Vape till her heart's content all
right let's play this video since now
we've confirmed that it's real real of
this transgender American reporter for
Ukraine thing
all right
it's muted still no that's muted but
what was the other thing that we just
said official top
there we go no this works we had we
didn't get to see the the speaking part
this gives us more details having been
uh in Ukraine almost 520 days in a
variety of Civilian and Military
capacity all right I think she just went
there but he that it went there because
of the flag they're like ah it's the
trans Flags so I'm good do we have them
uh speaking though the other questions
all right let's see that one because
this is a real thing this is a real
thing we're not making this up this is
happening on the Fly and by the way Matt
is is new helping with this uh the
system over here so you know all right
Maddie or something yeah you'll notice
that
Jewels
carry out genocide against both
ukrainians and Russians alike
Vlad Putin bathes in the blood and
children and enjoys it they're in a
first name this is why the dictatorship
that's Mr Impaler to you
and why that's ridiculous they call me
Mr unpassed
[Music]
foreign
remarked on how Dynamics is investing in
America from a factory in Milwaukee
Wisconsin which we've already done it we
try to keep this down to one a week but
yeah it's just it just brings us to part
two of this week in Biden if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump then you ain't black
President Joe Biden y'all
[Applause]
uh oh
well I'm a little underwhelmed aren't
you all
I think I messed up
y'all please vote for me okay
[Applause]
but then
when I signed the bipartis influencer
again which if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
Trump and you ain't black okay that's
not fair the lady introduced him she was
confused her her Visions based on
thermal identification
I was going to say never joke good job
vote for me y'all
I love how she bailed she she just like
well this is not gonna work yeah in
comedy you got to stay up high maybe
yeah your headliner's not there you
better get do some more time yeah his
jail should be you know yes stage left
going yeah yeah stretch it stretch it
she's like I'm underwhelmed y'all and
I'm like every single day all of us are
underwhelmed by him underwhelmed should
mean you have expectations now following
the event uh this is something else
people are talking about and look this
just to be clear I don't like I don't
run all of my own social media like I
understand it but it's the president of
the United States or former vice
president United some people call him
president of the United States some
people call him former Vice President of
the United States I call him former Vice
President of the United States because I
respect the office that's true so the
account for the White House Press
Secretary Karen Jean-Pierre tweeted and
deleted the following which was clearly
meant to be in Biden's voice it said
investing in America means investing in
all of America when I ran for president
I made a promise I'll leave no part of
the country behind that actually
happened to us wait what how so
when our social media guy was doing it
oh yeah it happens the accounts get
confused like Gerald tweeted uh what
I'll be posting uh the top three moves
everyone should know inside and out uh
to be proficient in Jiu Jitsu stay tuned
yeah that was probably that was probably
meant for Yeah Tim Tim tweeted out a Joe
Lewis caught in another rabbit Last
Night A Life Lesson protein is life bite
pressure of 500 PSI bug never had a
chance he's allergic to dogs
actually I need to be honest about mine
um so I'm really sorry about that what's
from so this one I I did it and it was
my my bad but it was supposed to be me
so it was supposed to be here where was
it it was posted to that explains well
it's from my account yeah yeah exactly
so the wife and I just had the most
amazing bottle of Pinot Noir I picked it
Somalia and all just Heavenly hashtag
date night well that one stinks forever
and I that does Sting no why did we give
Gerald access to your account I didn't I
didn't I you know you know it's a toggle
thing and I didn't toggle it through the
right account the lesson is don't throw
stones
[Music]
[Applause]
unless you're in Iran yes
I don't don't live in I mean you
shouldn't live in a glass house anyway
it's not structural yeah it's not great
well it's very hot come on yeah I mean
unless you're living in the house that
was used for the you know for the photo
session for uh Billy Joel's there's big
glass houses and it's a fantastic album
oh it is yeah nice nice house too it's
just it is a nice sound practice Yeah
it's no it's not practical not with the
Texas storms
so
we like to consider ourselves
[Laughter]
you would just get to see people being
cooked yes your house just turns to sand
what are you gonna do
I don't know if this is too soon or not
but do me a favor research bring up guns
and gear had a really funny tweet about
ordering a Hawaiian pizza oh no no no no
no no that is funny it's a little dark I
think I don't think it was his tweet I
think it was uh somebody else from his
account yeah yeah yeah so yeah
somebody find it real fast slow news day
you guys okay with it but we do have a
lot to get to
kind of we do there's a lot there's
international news and really look this
is one thing we've always told you we're
not going to Simply you have a lot of
news channels out there look at they
just have to regurgitate things recycle
things it gives us some freedom to
either have more fun or uh you know
stake out some Evergreen topics that
hopefully end up being more
I guess I should say more useful to you
our our role here is to serve you
everyone's serving a master it could be
primarily sponsors primarily big Tech
advertising oh we serve you we serve mug
Club largely you're watching for free
you're enjoying uh what mug Club
provides and consider signing up at
lotto.com
that's dark hey almost burnt
so here at lotto's crowd I'd like to
consider ourselves pretty astute on
global issues we didn't tweet that we're
saying someone else we didn't start the
pizza fire now that brings us
to the first edition and hopefully uh
one of few
Crowder's World corner
[Music]
oh they went heavy metal that's the NWO
font yeah that's awesome that's cool it
was that's because they're Crowder's
corner is the cream of the crop yeah
my little ones I love it now I said what
does Macho Man say oh yeah
oh yeah
we were working on a sketch he's so
colorful they go ah I go Macho Man oh
yeah I don't have that's so cute a lot
of fun I thought the first one oh my
wife's gonna hate me for saying this I
would jokingly say 9999
yeah I was making fun of him gloriously
tall blonde and blue eyes and he did it
he'd literally one day just went like
when he was super young nine nine nine
nine oh no and it was like that's
hilarious
he says it to his Jewish teacher
it makes it look really silly it does it
does yeah that's what that was the goal
all along
silly people North Korea
uh bad Korea as it's known they've
broken their silence on the United
States military Defector Travis King but
here's the thing uh the reason that they
are breaking their silence uh is of
course propaganda but it's also really
it's pretty funny first in case you
haven't heard here's a news clip this is
the 23 year old U.S soldier in North
Korean custody this morning a U.S
official says private Travis King has
served two and a half years in the
military he bolted across the border
effectively handing himself over to Kim
jong-un's isolated government
how bad must life be for you to flee
North Korea well here's the thing and
it's propaganda right where they they
said they said Travis can't confess that
he had decided to come over to dprk
democratic people but whatever North
Korea bad Korea I'm not going to do
their bidding for them James can confess
he had to come over to dprk as he
harbored ill feeling against inhuman
maltreatment and racial discrimination
within the U.S army
so Travis King is claiming racism but
there's a little there are a few key
details he was actually facing uh two
allegations of assault in South Korea he
pled guilty to one of the assaults in
destroying public property and was
facing extradition extradition to the
United States but this is this is what
they do right they're trying to Echo
just like we talked about China with
marriage if they can see the cracks in
the United States look at what these
people see as a valuable tool in
destroying the country right black lives
matter that's what they want you to
think
he fell for it and is now the only black
person in North Korea
to be fair though North Koreans are
pretty Progressive on on that King was
treated fairly cordially upon his
arrival they made him feel at home
what's up
now out of context that would seem bad
but we also have exclusive footage of
King having his first meal in uh uh bad
Korea
damn Chan some greasy
ain't got no better food like some
chicken wings some baby back ribs some
fries or something else
[Laughter]
and then he assaulted him yeah well and
now he's trying to flee somewhere else
and by the way that first clip of Jackie
Chan you know the the what's up mind now
we can't even say you couldn't do that
in the film today and here's the thing I
know people say well well it's because
we've Advanced no no there is nothing
racist about that joke there's nothing
racist about that bit about Jackie it's
funny because he's a fish out of water
who doesn't even understand English and
is trying to make friends with black
people and he hears them talk that way
and you can't put that in a film I I I'm
not just saying this isn't hyperbole
here we've lost something we've lost
something because you know what black
people loved rush hour and I think you
know the Asians who were allowed to
watch I don't know if they showed it in
China they like Russia yeah well Jackie
Chan was going on the uh the the China
apology tour for a long time yeah he
said well he's yeah he's a propaganda
for a little while yeah he also can't
fight his way out of a wet paper bag
what no come on we went to the Peking
Opera they just it's acrobatics with
fake punches okay I still like it it's
fun I like his Drunken Master stuff what
he does with a broom and a mop and it's
like you know he takes up it's good like
five eyes I like he does his own stunts
that's what I was talking about with
brooms and mops well no he really jumps
on stuff too yeah it's funny when he
misses it is funny
[Laughter]
button by the way if you're watching on
Rumble right now smash that Rumble
button it uh it just kind of it doesn't
really rumble's fair to us so the
algorithm doesn't matter so much there
hit the like button on YouTube and my
club only exists because of Rumble did
you have something you wanted to say we
want to move on too I think we need to
move on to a country that we all love
and adore yeah yeah Iran Oh I thought
you're gonna say Australia
ah Iran so uh while we're talking about
money uh the former Vice President Biden
Administration they just uh agreed to
unfree six billion dollars oh my gosh an
Iranian Assets in exchange for five now
before we go to clip five American
prisoners just to be clear we're doing
these exchanges with prisoners Russia
still does have The Merchant of death
[Laughter]
because of us yeah yeah I just want in
case you were wondering they do in fact
still have the Merchant of death and
you'll be happy to know that he's living
very comfortably so uh here's a clip of
blinken trying to make this make sense
last week we confirmed that Iranian
authorities released five U.S citizens
from prison to house arrest
and two Americans who wish to remain
private
most have been in prison since before
this Administration took office
one has been held for nearly eight years
none should have been detained in the
first place
1.2 billion dollars per person
I'm not good at math or anything but
geez better invite a invent a longer
lasting light bulb or something right
who you think you got Chelsea Clinton
yeah that was pretty good throwback
that's pretty good was that was that
Chris tiger he said that in in the oh
that's right it was rush hour two I
didn't always understand what he said I
would have to wait till the end of his
phrase
I'm gonna have to shoot you man I'm like
oh I got the left one yeah so you're
angry
I couldn't tell
um so obviously some people are
concerned about this yeah because it's
Iran
yeah
and uh Donald Trump had the best foreign
policy with Iran if you screw around too
much I will just kill you yes exactly
and brag about it right I won't even do
like a Seal Team that nobody knows about
right and so yeah I did it critics like
Mike Pompeo are saying this could be
like the concern is that obviously it
could be used for you know nuclear
capabilities uh the Exception by the way
is that these funds can be unfrozen uh
solely for humanitarian Aid which
apparently people this is why you don't
trust experts when they say oh hold on a
second this person has no experience in
politics we need to elect someone that
experience yeah Lincoln actually
believes that Iran is going to be using
the money for humanitarian Aid I would
trust my mechanic
in his office before him here he is the
funds in question are not American Funds
they're not American taxpayer money they
are Iranian funds that have been uh so
it's fake money in South Korea
for a number of years they send that
money to Ukraine from day one of our
sanctions there has always been an
exemption for the use of funds
for humanitarian purposes
[Music]
it doesn't get old no one's getting out
on scathe today
I'm next
is Rachel Ziegler oh yeah that's right
that little bra just made my list of
things to do today uh I mean insult
anything I don't mean anything violent
and I don't mean anything sexual just be
clear I mean that I don't like that
she's an entitled to a little brat right
and that these people are at the helm of
American culture by the way we do have
exclusive pictures
um you know we do a little news here uh
the funds being put to humanitarian use
so yeah yeah
come on
what what do you think they're going to
use that for like really hey I don't
know what would you use billions of
dollars for yeah if you were the country
who by the way all references are
available at lottery.com right they kill
people for political points of view and
torture them right this is ingrained
into their law uh ethnic religious
oppression of course women uh and of
course LGBT they throw them off really
see if they can fly they haven't found
one yet no they haven't still searching
they miss they misconstrued the idea of
fairy dust
by the way blinken isn't that the guy
who bought the the Afghan people like
the Taliban wasn't going to come back in
control and they're going to let women
stay in universe cities and it took six
days that's correct to happen yeah
University Taliban came back into Power
I think it was within like a three-day
period he just showed up he showed up to
an empty lot he's like this was supposed
to be Taliban DeVry
you lied to us really
I thought your assistant was a woman and
she was a phoenix
so
is the University of Phoenix still a
thing I don't know that was one of the
first ones made fun of you've spent a
lot of things do they still exist I
thought you spent a lot of time at
University of Phoenix yeah now I said I
don't know if it's still a thing is it
yeah it's got to be a thing yeah I guess
it's got to be they sponsor a stadium I
think for the Cardinals who knows yeah
is there anything else you want to get
into on the Internet it's just how silly
we are for crying out like giving the
money to Ukraine giving Over The
Merchant of death and now six people
like oh it's not our funds it's their
funds that we've Frozen
they're still universities how about how
about no involvement with evil regimes
how about that is can that be a starting
point I understand at certain points in
history the enemy of my enemy is my
friend I get it but that's not really
where we are right now there doesn't
need to be any no there's no reason to
send money to these people it's it
basically it needs to be like hey you're
detaining two Americans I don't know who
the other people were they didn't sound
very American maybe they are I don't
know maybe they immigrated over but they
sounded like people that they were just
illegally holding and it's like how
about you let them go or we do uh Donald
Trump part two we still have more
missiles that we can send and by the way
that's a nice Frappuccino you have right
now I'm sure you're going to want to be
able to drink that we could see you sir
did he have it from did he have a
frappuccino you missed it it's just like
we're watching you oh oh oh oh oh oh I
thought because you had a frappuccino
this morning no I didn't it was iced
coffee oh I'm sorry that's right that's
right that's right you keep accusing me
I didn't that's true it was false
accusation let Josh know he'll be in
Richmond Virginia this weekend by the
way come bring me a frappuccino I know
it I know it mocha cookie you play both
sides of the fence you guys come against
me it's the problem yeah lied about the
Grande I've been gaslighted Frappuccino
so
here's here's let's go back to the
United States you know or as you know I
like to think of it and the only place
that really matters now
um it's fair your dollar the American
dollar now it's worth less than it used
to be that's true
because they print it in the money
machine yeah uh but your dollar does
mean something now you've heard me say
in the past that just buy Cuts uh sorry
boycotts don't work in the absence of
buy Cuts in other words there has to be
some competition there has to be a
replacement we have seen now a method of
action through you that is effective and
we've seen it several times with giant
companies in other words when people say
what are you going to do with x billion
dollar international corporation well
now we have a bit of a blueprint so
yesterday
we'll go through these examples we have
Bud Light you have Target you have uh
Disney
go to the long shot I was scratching my
foot under my desk and then my foot
flung out and it hit it yeah oh my my
toe hurts
recluse or something I think I might
yeah
no it's a different bite okay you're
gonna walk funny I know
been bitten by a brown recluse tell me
what the phases are I think I might you
know lose a toe so death one phase death
yeah pretty simple necrosis I believe
they call it now
uh that's the death of the cells the
skin cells and stuff so death I was
right yeah but individual cells yeah
well I got a Mexican friend that doesn't
leave the house is he a brown recluse
he's a brown Jesus
thank you I believe the original Jesus
was anyway so he's just yes yes
talking to you Hector
I'll just get out there I'm just
picturing like a Mexican Howard Hughes
he's pissing in jars and people confuse
it for some kind of thing all right
so back on topic I guess
the boycotts and boycotts you're talking
about billions and billions and billions
hundreds of billions of dollars lost
because of you right and that's the same
model on the other side of that coin
with mug Club you guys can support what
it is that you like and you guys can now
boycott what it is that you don't like
and this is why the big Tech war is so
important right because this this only
happens if you can reach people if you
can reach Kindred Spirits that's why
they want to shut you down that's why
they want you to feel isolated well look
at the numbers now you are not alone
there are far more of you than you have
been told if you were to live your life
going through grade school going through
Public Schools going to University and
if you watch mainstream news or go to
the movies every band you listen to
every piece of entertainment that you
used to consume would tell you to vote
one way would tell you that everyone
believes
that the world is that way one point of
view an incredibly leftist point of view
the numbers now show that's not true and
that's why it's super important that you
are able to congregate and to
communicate with people who share your
values it's more important than ever so
yesterday Target
announced Cuts uh to both it's full year
sales and their profit expectations so
it's 390 million dollars wow under the
original projections and a lot of money
to put another little kind of I guess
feather in your cap there's 15 billion
dollars is the market cap that has also
been lost this year wow for Target
that's a huge drop 15 billion that's
what I don't know three prisoner
exchanges
or one and a half merchants of death yes
yes exactly
but this brings us to the gas leather
and we'll get to some other examples the
media wants you to think
that you have no power that that it's
this Leviathan that the people who have
formed that every weapon that is formed
against you it's so powerful you might
as well just give up it doesn't work all
is last they say
that was your cue clipped out one light
is so boycotted boycotts rarely work
that's what multiple experts said when
beer drinkers took their shot at
America's best-selling beer Bud Light
buckle up
it's about to get worse 27 billion
dollars and market cap lost since May
dang it's Bud Light and how's it
[Music]
that's okay you can bring that up yeah
yeah and by the way we have an exclusive
interview with the CEO of Anheuser-Busch
we do yeah it's coming up in a little
bit I completely forgot to mention okay
yeah yeah but no one really cares about
the guy no not anymore and those are
Bush it's been so effective
that they're unloading other brands as a
result of lost sales that's important to
note because this is remember I always
said don't just say I'm not going to
drink Bud Light and then go straight to
another and azerbush brand which is like
Modelo which is the number one brand
well depends if you're in the US are
international they don't do it here they
do it internet no Bud Light I'm a shock
top man
I'm more of a Budweiser guy not Bud
Light
like what if someone said I'm a shock
top man I'd be like I don't believe it
you don't exist and you can say that
because of a tattoo that's right yeah
he's a homo
that would be a shock bottom
he's more of a zema guy
Bacardi ice
white claw so the Anheuser-Busch CEO
Michael duchris is that am I pronouncing
it right close enough I've only ever
read it because I've never heard a
report about him said uh well it turns
out people basically they want to enjoy
their beer uh without the debate
here is the realization yeah
yeah I thought people wanted beer that
pushed you know transgenders with them
kids and like we have a can of a crate
but it turns out uh beer almost has
nothing to do with that
who knew actually if you're found
holding a Bud Light now it's a sign that
you're gay I think uh I think I can say
we were all caught off guard by this no
one could have possibly foreseen
everyone except for you every single
person just like that reporter boycotts
don't work okay
sure about that so yeah you sure about
that care about that Clark so uh to
discuss this and more and I do respect
anyone who enters the arena um we
actually uh sent our on the ground
correspondent Thomas Finnegan to uh
procure an exclusive interview with uh
Michael ducharist the CEO of Bud Light
foreign
this is exciting uh sir you have the
floor
it is all yours
hi Stephen yeah what's going on I
thought you had an you have the
interview Force right well it kind of
fell through but I figured
as they say a picture is worth a
thousand words
and
this stack of unsold Bud Light speaks
for itself
are you that's not
are you a person Finnegan
that's a genuine question not rhetorical
Are you a
little G
are you no
[Music]
I apologize comment below if you never
want to see that man again
and I won't be able to do anything
because he still has a I don't know what
we need to stop doing the five-year
contract it's minimum wage so it does
work in our favor yeah
so Disney is another company that's been
in uh in hot water uh they've been in a
downward spiral Spiral wow that was my
only mispronunciation with style smile
yeah downward spiral since they decided
that uh and it's not here's the thing
it's not that they disagree with you
it's that they've decided when people
say woke
what they really mean is they're
describing a worldview that hates you
that hates everything America stands for
just to be clear it's not that these
people disagree with you slightly they
want you silenced and removed from any
platform and being able to speak at all
they want your children removed from you
if you don't agree with their evil
Progressive ideology so we throw around
woke or cancel culture let's be really
clear woke right we're talking about
Ultra far leftists people who believe
that men and women are a figment of your
imagination that your money is not your
own that your family is not your own and
that your country is not your own that's
what woke means and when we say cancel
culture people throw it out what that
means is a lose your livelihood culture
let's let's be really clear about the
severity of it cancel culture what does
that mean we won't be able to work and
you'll be eliminated from platforms oh
so basically the same reason that wars
were fought when someone would come over
and burn my farm yeah those were
fighting actions that's what cancel
culture is wokeness describes people who
hate you and that personifies Disney to
the letter now their stock price good
news it's down 56 percent
yeah that what they've lost in market
cap wow yeah and that's incredible seven
thousand uh jobs have been cut as far as
layoffs that's 3.2 percent of their
Workforce apparently they lost about uh
this is from Screen Rant all the
references are available 900 million
dollars this summer alone whoops
that's a few misses yeah yeah so it's a
couple 900 million dollars is not a
mundane detail Michael I thought people
would like it
but my Disney Plus subscription keeps
going through does it keep going through
it keeps going through the stream oh
yeah I wouldn't do that yeah for you
they have to pair it uh with that I
stole it that got somebody else's
account good for you yeah I'm an
American you're like Robin Hood yeah
man that movie line whoever's watching
right now let's see you're gonna have to
that one's a little more obscure so
here's the thing people would often say
well you know it's a profit motive if
you don't like it don't shop there no no
that's that's that's not really true
especially when you're also talking
about industries that are bailed out by
the way or enjoy all kinds of
subsidization or tax benefits from the
government and they get to pick winners
and losers we'll do more on that
probably another segment but of course
we've done that on airlines on health
insurance companies right on energy
companies the same thing happens with a
lot of these companies in the
entertainment industry the people who
hate you it's not just a profit motive
because if it was just a profit motive
and that wouldn't make it okay
to propagate evil
um it is an ideological one because
Disney is still doubling down yeah
they're they're planning to save their
brand buy more wokeness again woke means
they hate you they're going to do a snow
white remake
with dwarves that aren't dwarves
a completely spineless feckless Prince
buys the swimsuits a Target
it's helpful to be able to tuck
and Snow White is snow Brown now I don't
have a problem with the fact that she's
brown I'm just saying everything about
this has to be changed when it doesn't
really need to be changed
all right okay fine black mermaid I mean
who cares I mean it's maybe not the most
believable mermaid but
I also like how Disney doesn't have any
like new ideas right that's what have we
done before that's worked let's do that
again yeah that could have been a whole
new movie right it could have been a
different storyline different people
yeah yeah just like that
close your eyes yeah no that's because
they because they they travel in packs
and they attack from behind all the
words homosexuals yeah
made me think of Jasmine oh
well also Ariel was quite cute yes
Jasmine was
so dismissive I didn't dismiss your
crush
gingers bestiality it smelled like fish
that wasn't her fault
he's doing commercials for Monistat
seven no
I want to be who are the yeasties are oh
this broad likes it
you started it yeah it's fair you
started it the slow news day go screw
yourself
but this is this does matter look I've
said I think this matters more than
taxes why because it's something you can
directly affect immediately you've got
to wait until someone gets into office
assuming that we have you know continued
most fair and secure elections of all
time all time and hope that they do what
it is that you ask them to do as it
relates to taxes or as it relates to
foreign policy you can vote with your
dollar every single day now when I say
that these people meaning these will
come these leftist companies I've always
used the term leftist I know some people
use it now I don't say liberal book is
something that'll come and go because
it'll be reappropriated just like fake
news was then hijacked by the right so
leftists people like this Rachel Ziegler
who's she's the lead in this film
when I just said they hate everything
about you and they hate all the things
that you love
um just please take note of the tone it
seems like she's hell-bent on this film
just tanking and she dislikes everything
that we all maybe enjoyed about Snow
White check the tone
I just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely wrote a snow white that is
not going to be saved by the prince he's
not gonna be saved for The Prince and
she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be serious
I watched it once and then I went on the
ride in Disney World which was called
Snow White scary adventures
doesn't sound like something a little
kid would like was terrified of it never
Revisited Snow White again because
you're weak
Ness
of an ice age for every hour that it is
streamed online oh the original cartoon
came out in 1937 and very evidently so
um there is a big focus on her love
story
um with a guy who literally stalks her
yeah weird weird
we didn't do that this time just that's
something that entitled broads and by
the way to be clear this is just another
white Suburban entitled person who who
has brown skin just to be clear that
yeah you know it's really weird they do
that so they seem like they're sarcastic
or they're bitter and they know
something that you don't it is what some
it is what someone does when they don't
really know what they're talking about
and they are arrogant and they think
that they know better than you hold on a
second wait you are being paid millions
of dollars millions of dollars to wear a
dress I'm sorry that you couldn't walk
around the set in Spanx look millions of
dollars to be a dwarfless snow white who
no one asked for weird yeah you know
what's weird that these people just shut
the up I'm sorry put on your
earmuffs I'm sorry just shut up just
please shut take your millions of
dollars and about the film and
quite I can't imagine I don't know why
Disney doesn't slap a lawsuit shoot on
this person I know I'm gonna go out and
crap on the product it's like someone
imagine Halle Berry going out and doing
the Pepsi commercials and like yeah but
it kind of sucks exactly how how much do
you have to think of yourself to think
you know something that has really
become Americana a story that almost
every single person knows about Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves that has
been around for almost a hundred years
we need to do it better this time by
remaking it with me right well that's
something that's something a white man
would sound it's like the whole story
stalking her no that's not stalking it's
a love story you that obnoxious
lilt that obnoxious lilt yeah they she
complained about that Snow White ride at
the Disney World a park that is built
based on the fact that that movie is so
successful and built that company
it's
[Laughter]
it's one of those
little let me know if you've run into it
if you've run into it with arrogant
arrogant young women and I will say this
it is a problem by the way okay so we
have this new segment coming up black
and white and gray issues right let's go
to an area of town that is largely black
and I think that we have more common
ground Than People realize because the
media wants us all to be divided you
would be surprised if you are a
Christian conservative how much more you
have in common with the average black
American
than someone like this then someone like
Ziegler
and the one con you were there Tool Man
yep I don't know we had five six
conversations uh they were all
productive we didn't agree on everything
but they were all productive like
hugging hey man love you brother great
let's uh hopefully we'll follow up the
one
where couldn't get a word in edgewise
and by the way this is not a debate the
one where they were entirely was a young
woman a young woman while we were
leaving yes like oh you got cameras yes
can I be on camera sure and then they
were saying don't air this which man you
will maybe we won't because they were so
aggressive I mean they went through
Thomas Jefferson raped all of his slaves
and if I said wait hold on a second what
it was white privilege white fragility
right they talked about all of these
issues that only racism could only uh
come from a position of power uh
apparently the Beanie Baby Corporation
is racist because they won't make the
Princess and the Frog Beanie Babies I
don't I don't even know I wasn't
familiar with it I mean I went long on
Beanie Babies I lost my shirt so I have
my own issues with them but racism is
not Chief amongst them and at the end of
it the mom goes that's the future right
there that's the future right there
isn't it isn't it doesn't it look good
and I said you know what I think there's
I think there's potential there she goes
there's a lot more than potential you
know what I will never tell my children
and you should never tell your children
that they're perfect that they're
perfect if you have a son he shouldn't
feel like crap because he was born a
male and eff if you have a daughter she
shouldn't think that she's blameless
because she was born a woman you need to
tell your kids that they are all
fearfully and wonderfully created in the
image of God the rest of the respect in
their life is earned through their
actions boy or girl but we don't say
that you know what no young man has ever
heard unless he's gay is you're perfect
you have no room for improvement
do you think anyone on that set where
she goes on I should be paid extra to
have to wear this custom designed dress
do you think anyone's going man you're
kind of an ungrateful brat not the guy
carrying the heavy camera the guy boom
mic all day long who's getting paid
scale or whatever and the guy having to
listen to you mope around oh I know tell
me more but look at look at the bubble
that they live in the Gal Gadot pops in
and like haha we're not doing that again
and everybody's like yeah and the camera
is like yeah tell us more and we're all
like what yeah you're an idiot that's
the entire story why why would you come
out and say the story sucks but go watch
the movie yeah and by the way the whole
in case you wonder Snow White I'm trying
sometimes I get that in Cinderella
confused it's a prince right there's a
prince yeah there's the prince is the
one Snow White part which one's Sleeping
Beauty is it a prince and Snow White I
want to make sure that I'm clear if the
boys
they're usually princes yes okay so
here's the thing he's not stalking her
and this is why they try and change it
this is the problem with feminism okay
if I'm not mistaken and he's a prince uh
if someone out there can confirm because
they kind of bleed together I know
there's a witch and an apple and a
mirror and I don't know which one's in
which but oh yeah snow witch she ate the
apple and basically died yeah yeah so
Snow White is the prince right yes no it
has the fever there yeah
he's not
no that's no fingerprints Sleeping
Beauty well again let's let it never be
said that they've been original ever now
ever since that anti-semitic mouse was
whistling on a steamboat
but
my point is
he's a prince he doesn't need to stalk
you he's a prince okay he's PR that's
how you know he's PR it means that he
wants to be with you he's a prince you
think he needs to go wake up some
from a slumber that was induced by a
witch he has easier paths to Victory
that's his love for you he's willing to
overcome it that was seen as something
by the way there was chivalrous back in
the day not the false white nighting of
retweeting a feminist in the hopes that
you get laid being a power bottom this
is It's a prince
you want a prince and now they're even
saying I can't believe he was stalking
her this is the perverse this is why a
huge portion of young men don't want to
get married and there are women then
when they reach their 30s wrong side of
40 saying there aren't men worth
marrying he was stalking her he pursuing
her he pursued her and saved her life
yes it's not 1937 anymore well that
movie wasn't about 1937 either no it
wasn't it was about a time when any
woman would just be really happy to not
die yeah at the age of 24 and be with a
man that has a little bit of money in a
house yes and a loved her yeah and who
loved her and rescued her from the seven
weirdos Cinderella you can look at
Cinderella and go oh yeah Cinderella is
about well the Prince why is she why
does she need to chase him no no hold on
think about this this man had options
Cinderella is a good example he had
options and instead he wanted the woman
who wasn't wealthy he wanted the woman
whose heart he viewed as most pure
that's a good thing that's a good thing
and you can go and screw yourself if you
want to erode at that fabric that has
been the basis of society that is a good
lesson to learn sure there are
traditional roles in Cinderella he found
maybe had a foot fetish we don't know
the shoe thing it's a little bit weird
it is a little weird but he said no no
no no hold on a second all these women
who they're telling me that I should be
with they're wealthy they're shallow
they're you know they're all these are
all shallow uh Gold Digging here
I want to find the woman who who doesn't
care about my title the woman who I
think I who I think might love me for me
and I love her for her
it's an allegory it's not I can't
believe that Snow White watch you're
supposed to chase them and the white
what is he supposed to put on the shoes
and then
shut up
no does not please keep doing this and
losing money where were you left was
there something in there
the way you said it just sounded like
that song
uh oh she likes me for me yeah yeah the
Leonardo yes I'm tough like dirty here
yeah that guy
not 1937 well in some ways maybe it
should be yeah she's like I'm not gonna
be oh I can't remember the rest of her
quote but it's something like I'm not
gonna go that route that they did in
1937 where I need somebody to save me
I'm focused on being the leader I know I
can be I'm like of what seven little
people oh that's right all right that's
right oh you're the writer Rachel
Ziegler I'm not gonna do what oh you're
the writer and producer collect your
check say your lines and shut up okay
when people say shut up and actors
they're like you shouldn't be yeah yeah
yes yes in this instance yes especially
when you're young every 17 year old 16
year old 18 year old thinks they know
everything we used to tell them you
don't know a whole lot now we say oh
yeah you know everything because you're
a brave insert whatever oppressed class
here shut up
and you know what's even worse than what
this person is saying now when they're
young is that they live in a bubble
where they won't even be embarrassed by
it once they're older and they should be
smarter it's like they freeze in time as
permanent retards
well most retards are stop it I'm sorry
stop it it's true they're not Frozen in
Time get rid of it yeah some of them
aged an accelerated rate depending on
the condition
we're sorry
the tours I was making a joke I was just
no it's true it's true he's telling the
truth true facts
now the dwarves not being dwarves
this is another you can thank Peter
Dinklage uh for that one who decided to
pull up the half ladder behind him
well you know it's really Progressive to
um cast uh literally no offense to
anything but I was a little
taken back by the very very they're very
proud to cast a a Latino actress as Snow
White yeah but you're still telling the
story of snow it's not white yeah Seven
Dwarfs sure
we'll take take a step back and look at
what you're doing there yeah I know it
makes no sense to me well oh so you're
Progressive in one way and then but
you're still making that backward oh
story about seven dwarves living in a
cave to get what the are you doing
man you know no it should have been Snow
White and these seven full-grown rapists
they didn't live in a cave either they
worked in a cave yes that's true they
lived in a house right it was also a
fictional cartoon yeah and by the way
you're the ones who want to be called
dwarves not midgets that's not our fault
yeah I always thought it was way more
ofism right yeah so dwarfism
would you prefer a role in Wolf of Wall
Street where you get thrown through the
air
that's your choice you angry little elf
yeah I would like to see that
you were saying it's messed up that he
yeah it's messed up that he's saying all
this stuff after making a whole career
being cast because he's a little person
yes he's not getting cast in uh Game of
Thrones as just a coincidentally being a
dwarf right they were like we need a
little guy for this show right yeah it's
forecast as an angry elf in the film elf
and now you want to yeah yeah and you
want to now you want to take that's even
that's so much I thought about that
right that's and I want to take work
from other little people right because
it hurt his feelings he thinks that the
story is is somehow this backward story
I'm like oh my God it's it's fiction
these people are so loud
so Snow White can't be white and the
dwarves can't be the dwarves can't be
Dwarfs okay this seems but it's about
changing everything it's about
permeating everything and trying to it's
these little little sort of tectonic
shifts of the ground beneath you that
they're they're trying to just all the
time and then you all of a sudden go
wait wait hold on a second
they're they're selling swimsuits that
hide my son's dick at Target
how'd you get there how did you get
there when it's concerted effort from
people who hate everything you stand for
I'll tell you exactly Snow White was wet
because this was largely by the way you
know they don't do a bunch of white folk
tales uh in countries that aren't all
white I don't know if you know this like
in China they're not always concerned
with diversity no in their Chinese film
or if you go uh somewhere I don't know
what kind of film industry they have in
Uganda I have no idea but my point is
we're the only ones concerned with it
not everything has to be changed but
that is seen through the lens the reason
things have to be changed when when you
say there's no there's no perceptible
reason for this change ah then why do
they think it needs to why do they think
that Snow White cannot be white
why do they think that the little
mermaid cannot be white why do they
think that these children's characters
have to be gay and Shay and share an
on-screen gay kiss why do they think
that Cuties with children twerking
should be thrust into your feet why do
they think that dwarves should be
full-grown non-binary men why do they if
you look at me there's no reason to
change that ask yourself why they are
and you always come back to the same
answer and I am speaking in absolute
series it relates to Hollywood when you
start with the question why are they
changing something that doesn't need to
be changed it's because they hate you
it's because they hate everything you
are about it's the same reason that that
Aussie broad was bitching about seeing
the American flag it's like garlic to a
vampire it's the last standing Republic
that's supposed to have free speech and
by the way primarily entirely founded on
judeo-christian values that these people
hate you know what else is but you know
what else is a portion of the
judeo-christian prescription for
relationships courtship
courtship that and I know what you'll
say oh this is back when women were
property no no no no no no you're wrong
we'll do another segment on that shut up
that's not what the biblical uh view of
relationships and marriages nope
incorrect women were not Christ was
basically the first feminist shut up
that's something that they also want to
remove the idea of courtship the idea of
a man courting and pursuing a woman
women out there is that the kind of
world you want to live in because you're
going to have an entire generation of
women who have duped other women into
thinking that they don't want a man to
pursue them and that generation event
will be terrified
terrified to pursue them lest they be
falsely accused of rape or being a
stalker hey that's better for the United
States of America we're going to play
age restricted or not unmuckle if you're
not a member a lot of credit.com it's
not a game that we could play at all
here on YouTube we could unrumble but of
course this is this is what Mud Club is
and you support we're funded by viewers
like you 89 annually Alex Jones's show
launches this Friday Friday he's so
excited he texted me at 11 o'clock last
night
yeah it was a Pepe Le Pew cartoon oh
okay why did he say that I think we
referenced it at one point I don't think
so I think he just wanted to know we did
you did you mentioned like going under a
ladder in the paint done and then
something I don't remember what it was
about but but then he decided to send it
48 hours later yeah hey remember this
Joe from two days ago yeah yeah so funny
I can't wait for the show though anyways
he's a fun dude or not Josh feierstein
is uh you're in Richmond Virginia right
Richmond Virginia at the Funny Bone with
JP Sears this Friday and Saturday I see
there hit like comment share sign up my
club age restricted or not we can't so
Rumble thank you YouTube piss off
[Applause]
[Music]